والنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم بين انه من
امان البيوت انه لابد ان يتلى فيها كتاب
الله عز وجل وان يذكر فيها
الذكر الحكيم لقول الله عز وجل ومن يعشو
عن ذكره الرحمن القيد له شيطان فهو له
قريب
وقال النبي الامين صلى الله عليه وسلم
مثل البيت الذي يذكر فيه الماء والبيت
الذي لا يذكر فيه الله كسل الحي والميت
ودائما يعني نحسن انفسنا بافكار كان يقول
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم في كل صباح
ومساء زي مثلا بسم الله الذي لا يضر فيه
شيء في الارض ولا في السماء وهو السميع
العليم اعوذ بكلمات الله التامه من كل
شيطان مهمه ومن كل عين لامه وقولي النبي
عليه الصلاه والسلام اعوذ بكلمات الله
التامات من شر ما خلق فهذا يعني امان
للبيوت ونسال الله سبحانه وتعالى ان يج